hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ich weiß dass sie immer Grundrezepte
sehen wollt und deswegen gibt es heute
das Grundrezept für den Rührteig
dafür nehmt ihr 200 Gramm weiche Butter
200 g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt vier Eier die sind
bereits auf Raumtemperatur etwas Milch
die ist auch auf Raumtemperatur 200 g
Mehl und Backpulver oder ihr verwendet
einfach das backmehl da ist nämlich
Backpulver schon enthalten der Rührteig
besteht auch nur aus wenigen Zutaten
wichtig ist dabei dass ihr für den
Rührteig die Zutaten rechtzeitig
rausstellt das heißt Butter Milch und
Eier müssen Raumtemperatur haben weil
sie das mal vergessen habt gibt's da
auch einige Tipps wie ihr das ganze
einfach schön weich bekommt bei der
Butter ist zum Beispiel so ihr könnt die
diesen butterblock einfach fein reiben
mit so einer Küchenreibe als würde man
käse reiben dann habt ihr nämlich schon
den ersten Tipp wie die butterweich wird
bei den Eiern ist es so dass ich die
Eier im Ganzen dann gerne einfach in
warmes Wasser einlege das ist so der
zweite Tipp und die Milch könnt ihr auf
dem Herd oder in der Mikrowelle einfach
kurz erwärmen das war's dann müsst ihr
eben nicht zwei Stunden vorher dran
denken die Zutaten rauszulegen sondern
könnt eben dann direkt loslegen wichtig
ist jetzt einfach die weiche Butter mit
Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt in der
Küchenmaschine oder auch mit dem
Handrührgerät richtig schön schaumig
rühren beim Rührteig war es früher so
dass man die rührmasse es hat die Oma
früher gemacht immer extrem lange
aufgeschlagen hat es ging so was den
ganzen Tag und irgendwann wurde dann
Backpulver erfunden denn entweder macht
man das ganze mechanisch dass man die
Butter und den Zucker eben ganz ganz
lange aufschlägt oder man gibt einfach
Backpulver mit dazu es war so dass Dr
Oetker nämlich ein Apotheker war und
früher ging man mit seinem Kuchenrezept
praktisch in die Apotheke und hat gesagt
ich habe hier ein Pfund Mail und habe
hier meine Zutaten wie viel Backpulver
brauche ich und der Apotheke hat es dann
zusammen gemischt und dann kam Dr Oetker
auf die Idee und hat gesagt ich mache
diese 16 Gramm Päckchen Backpulver und
die sind immer für einen Hund nehmen
immer für 500 Gramm und so kam das
Backpulver ins Spiel ja so ist doch dort
von einem Apotheker zu einem riesigen
backkonzern
[Musik]
so sieht die eierzuckermasse jetzt aus
richtig perfekt schön weiß cremig und
jetzt kommen die Eier dazu da achtet
jetzt drauf wie gesagt Raumtemperatur
müssen sie haben und jedes Ei wird
einzeln eingerührt für etwa 30 bis 60
Sekunden ansonsten kann es nämlich
passieren dass es ganze gerinnt wäre
auch nicht so schlimm dann müsste es nur
noch ein bisschen erwärmen also zum
Beispiel mit dem Heißluftfön oder ihr
stellt eine Schale mit warmem Wasser und
rührt dann weiter weil das passiert
schon mal dass die Eier Zuckermasse mit
der Butter einfach gerinnt und das ist
gar nicht schlimm das kommt nur daher
dass die Eier dann doch ein bisschen zu
kalt waren und die Butter dann einfach
flockig wird weil sie eben abkühlt also
gar nicht schön
kann passieren kann zum Beispiel auch
passieren wenn die Eier hier auf so
einer Steinplatte liegen dass sie dann
einfach zu sagen können alles möglich
und deswegen ist die warme Milch umso
wichtiger oder in dem Stadt warmer Milch
etwas Kaffee oder Likör oder einen
anderen Geschmack um den Teig einfach
geschmacklich so ein bisschen
abzuhandeln
[Musik]
so sieht die Masse perfekte aus und
jetzt vermischt ihr mehl mit Backpulver
17 beim backmehl muss ich das jetzt
nicht machen das backmil ist so fein das
kann man einfach direkt immer dazu
schütten und dann kommt die Milch dazu
und alles wird nur noch kurz verrührt
jetzt nehme ich wichtig Eier butter und
Zucker werden lange verrührt aber sobald
Mehl dazu kommt nur noch ganz kurz
verrühren
[Musik]
und so sieht der Teig jetzt richtig
perfekt aus ein Rührteig ist ein sehr
fettreicher und eierreicher Teig
deswegen schmeckt aber umso besser das
ist jetzt so ein Teig den man eben mit
Butter zubereitet und deswegen schmeckt
auch sehr gut nach Butter aber es gibt
auch Rührteige die kann man mit Öl
zubereiten dass sie Zubereitung anders
wenn ihr wollt mache ich da auch gerne
ein Basic Rezepte dazu und daraus wird
jetzt auch z.B Marmorkuchen zubereitet
Kastenkuchen Sandkuchen bei Sandkuchen
wird einfach Speisestärke noch bisschen
zugefügt dann schmeckt es ein bisschen
sandiger aber auch trockener muss man
sagen und ihr könnt da jetzt auch noch
Kakao mit dazugeben einfach mit etwas
mehr Flüssigkeit und dann habt ihr
einfach den perfekten rückkuchen ich
fühle den jetzt hier in meine Springform
[Musik]
streichst immer gern noch hier so ein
bisschen am Rand hoch dann backst du
nämlich noch gleichmäßiger
und dann wird der Kuchen direkt im
vorgeheizten Ofen gebacken auf mittlerer
bzw im unteren Drittel auf den Schienen
falls ihr einen Bosch Backofen habt mit
backsensor könnt ihr natürlich den
backsensor verwenden dann müsst ihr
nämlich nicht mehr die Temperatur die
heizat und die Zeit einstellen das macht
dann der Ofen ganz alleine für euch wenn
ihr meine Sallys Welt App habt könnt ihr
auch einfach die Einstellwerte direkt an
eurem Backofen senden ist auch nichts
mehr einstellen
[Musik]
der Kuchen ist jetzt perfekt gebacken
aus dem Ofen ich habe eine Stäbchenprobe
gemacht falls ihr mit wachsen so
arbeitet braucht ihr auch keine
Stäbchenprobe denn der Ofen sorgt quasi
dafür dass der Kuchen perfekt durch gabt
schaltet sich dann
automatisch Messer den Rührkuchen
rausnehmen
[Musik]
und das ist jetzt so der perfekte
Rührkuchen für aderlight Torten ihr
könnt damit eine Donauwelle zubereiten
einen Marmorkuchen einen Blechkuchen ihr
geht einfach in meine App tragt da ein
welche Backform Größe ihr haben wollt
also es ist Springform größer oder
kleiner eine rechteckige Form ein
Ofenblech und dann spuckt euch meine App
quasi die passende Zutaten raus die
richtige Zutaten Menge und ihr könnt
wirklich alles zubereiten ich hoffe ich
konnte euch mit diesem Video ganz
einfach erklären wie ihr einen
Rührkuchen machen könnt und zubereiten
könnt gerne zeige ich euch noch einen
Rührkuchen mit Öl wo man quasi eier und
Zucker zuerst berührt dann das Öl oder
andere Flüssigkeiten dazu nimmt das ist
praktisch eine andere Zubereitungsweise
und falls ihr sonst noch Fragen zur
anderen Teigarten habt oder Cremes oder
Grundrezepten schreibt einfach gerne und
dann hole ich das gerne beim nächsten
Mal nach also viel Spaß beim backen bis
zum nächsten Mal und tschüss
[Musik]